e quindi eccoci per un nuovo video del
milione oggi in particolare voglio
riempirvi di piccoli regali di natale ho
messo anche il cappello che lo mettevo
da un po volendo c'era anche questo ma
internet è mica un posto dove la gente
si ridicolizza pubblicamente oggi sono
qui per svelarvi un segreto un segreto
che ogni uomo di potere che si rispetti
ha un canale di youtube nascosto alla
fine del 2010 ho aperto un canale
chiamato sgombra la mente che è rimasto
inutilizzato per un paio di mesi finché
non mi sono detto ok potrei usarlo per
caricare ruba in più tutti quei video
che invece di buttare ho voluto tenere
in questo scantinato questo canale è
l'equivalente di quello scatolone che tu
trovi nell'armadio che aprì ed è pieno
di videocassette che non ti ricordavi di
avere tra l'altro questo canale non si
chiama neanche più sgombra la mente
perché da quando è arrivato google plus
google ha deciso che devi avere un nome
un cognome e se non hai un nome cognome
te lo diamo noi perché siamo onnipotenti
e adesso il canale si chiama marco de
gasperi grazie a youtube ed è qui che
oggi vi vorrei mostrare alcuni di questi
video partiamo in ordine e partiamo dai
più vecchi arrivando ai più nuovi
il primo video assoluto caricato si
chiama test hd ed è un testi in hd una
delle mie primissime telecamere in hd
dove c'era il fuoco manuale e io che ero
un inetto testa di cazzo mi affascinano
per il nulla quindi ho filmato alcuni
pupazzetti che c'erano sulla mia
scrivania il tutto contornato da una
colonna sonora assolutamente non
appropriata
o no
perché perché chi mi conosce da tanto
tempo lo sa io sono un appassionato
dello sfondo sfocato ormai una stronzata
ma per me avere lo sfondo sfocato voleva
dire ok se è arrivato allo step
successivo del tuo canale e questo è
quello che ne è venuto fuori
l'hai visto so che lo hai visto
ma sia finalmente n'è uno anch'io
lo sfondo sfocato
sei i viola lo so
un salutone a stefano che sarà
contentissimo di essersi rivisto in
questo video vecchio di migliaia di anni
e che ora l'ho usato senza il suo
permesso
e poi da lì ci sono altre prove una in
esterna una interna con un faro da 508
dall'altra che mi sta uccidendo ma manco
i camion c'erano quelli quei fari lì poi
si passa cosa un po più complesse tipo
la prima prova della sigla verso la
telecamera che provavo in quel periodo
era una canon 550d a cui poi ho comprato
un obiettivo da 50 mm e che fai non lo
provi completamente a caso tanto sanno
che non è contento questa gente tra
inutile partita chiocciola 48 meglio
dire non è che posso proprio il vice di
roma sono riina meno non capisco un
saluto a francesco e che ieri il tizio
qualunque che sarà contentissimo di
essere si è rivisto dopo centinaia di
migliaia di anni e che ho usato questo
video senza suo permesso
e parlando del tizio qualunque arriva al
momento ufficio quando ci siamo detti no
dai dobbiamo arrivare da qualche parte
non possiamo più fare video dalla
cameretta dei nostri genitori
prendiamoci un ufficio e lì come ogni
ufficio entrava e uscivano idee ogni due
secondi non ne abbiamo realizzato
neanche mezza mani entravano e uscivano
veramente un sacco e dalle nostre bocche
uscivano frasi di cui ci siamo pentiti
due secondi dopo tipo sai cosa sarebbe
figo una sit com
non riesco
venire qui
non c'è
ma proprio no
ma la voglia di cambiare di fare
qualcosa di diverso da lì in poi è
sempre più marcata non era ancora il
periodo in cui mi dicevo basta con le
recensioni ma era il periodo in cui
dicevo se le recensioni che è però in
parallelo è un'altra frase di cui mi
sono pentito subito che è uscita dalla
mia bocca è stata sai cosa ci vorrebbe
su youtube italia una serie è fatta da
due pupazzi di batman non solo siamo gli
scarti dei giocattoli ma siamo anche
scarti dei giocattoli di batman del muro
di pochi supereroi che non ha neanche i
superpoteri anche iron man non ai
superpoteri eppure va alla grande
iron man ha una tuta che gli permette di
volare sparare missili e non è neanche
del tuo franchise in realtà quell'idea
non era neanche così male però il
problema di tutte le mie idee che sono
da solo a farle fatti venivano fuori una
merda e quindi finivano nello scatolone
de gasperi e nel frattempo ovviamente ci
sono state altre prove colore prove
montaggio prove e musica un video super
segreto dove provolo cruz rift mi chiedo
come mai non l'abbia mai fatto vedere a
nessuno e poi il teaser di quella che
sarebbe dovuta essere una serie semi
animata sul canale perché avevo voglia
di scrivere qualcosa di serio quindi ho
contattato una ragazza le ho fatto fare
un sacco di lavori di disegni
inutilmente perché poi io purtroppo sono
così quando un'idea buona dico che
iniziò svilupparla poi vedo che al primo
errore dove che si evolverà in errori
molto più grandi di con ok lasciamo
perdere però lì iniziò le cose quello il
problema è un problema perché tu inizio
la cosa poi capisci che non la puoi fare
ma ormai iniziate quindi la blocchi e la
cantoni ed è questa la fine che ha fatto
moon
giusto io non ha idea di che cosa stia
succedendo qui ma vogliamo tornare a
casa
un salutone alla ragazza che aveva
disegnato tutto questo di cui purtroppo
non mi ricordo il nome di cui ho usato
poi il filmato senza permesso e non è
stato il primo vero e proprio progetto
che volevo fare al cento per cento ma
non ci sono riuscito perché sono una
testa di cazzo
e nel frattempo intanto caricavo altre
stronzate io e miei amici siamo
appassionati dei canali che vanno in
giappone ti fanno vedere tutti i luoghi
in cui mangiare i luoghi da visitare e
quindi perché non farci una parodia
abbiamo qua in questa zona di torino per
andare a mangiare l'orientale questo
video dura sei minuti e 41 è troppo
lungo per farvelo vedere tutto adesso
sappiate solo che fa morire dal ridere
per i motivi sbagliati
sono contento perché mi hanno anche
messo i fazzoletti smoccola ti metti
caso che mi dovevo fare andando a garda
noi ha tra l'altro fino a questo momento
vi ho saltato un sacco di video di
gaming che ho fatto molto prima
addirittura di aprire il canale perché
la mia vita consiste in quello giocare
tutto il giorno per che a 27 anni che
cazzo devi fare della tua vita
uno degli ultimi che non ho mai fatto
vedere nessuno è un montaggio di
stronzate di gta su pc a 60 frame al
secondo in slow motion con una musica
assolutamente non appropriate in
sottofondo questo ve lo posso far vedere
tutto
giusto
shi yu space cowboy ma la mia passione
per fare sketch comici brevi e di merda
non è mai passata e dopo finalmente aver
finito la prima stagione di game of
thrones con tutti i pop che mi ritrovo a
casa ho detto ci starebbe bene un video
corto corto del cazzo
noi siamo il miglior show della storia
della televisione
puoi dirlo forte sorella incredibilmente
attraente noi qui abbiamo tutto
ricostruzioni storiche immaginarie
azioni mozzafiato giganteschi misteri io
non so un cazzo abbiamo anche del
romanticismo
chiara c
tutte le guerre che ci stanno che sarà
mai un po di incesto e abbiamo perfino i
draghi e delle cacce frates che a chi
non guarda la serie e gli staranno sui
[ __ ] subito o dordei ma non dovevano
esserci anche gli start o piccolo
ingenuo giorni neve hanno avuto un
contrattempo io non so un cazzo anche se
metà del cast è andato [ __ ]
siamo comunque la miglior serie che ci
sia
mi annoio questo a me personalmente
piace ma è fatto di merda avrei potuto
rifarlo ma ho detto no non rende un po
una stronzata quindi lasciamolo perdere
un altro sketch che ho eliminato perché
gente molto più famosa di me l'ha fatto
poco prima di me è una piccolissima
parodia di quel video che aveva
spopolato di quella ragazza che cammina
per 10 ore a new york e viene fischiata
e commentata da tutti avevo fatto la mia
versione ma appunto me l'avevano
bruciata sul tempo
neanche uno schifo di commento
nessuno che mi salutasse nessuno che mi
fischia se nessuno che commentasse anche
solo il mio culo per ore nessuno mi ha
detto niente
e dire che sono uno che ci tiene al
fisico che passò tante ore a cercare di
tenermi bello per le altre persone per
cercare di non fare brutta figura e poi
succedono queste cose impensabili queste
sono cose che fanno riflettere un uomo
anche noi abbiamo dei sentimenti e poi
si arriva all'ultimo video che ho
caricato in questo canale è che per me è
molto importante e un test orrendo per
una prova di un week liscio
io sono sempre stato un appassionato del
letterman del jimmy kimmel del fallon e
perché no anche i nostrani satyricon di
daniele luttazzi essi si è di saverio
raimondo
adoro quel tipo di programma perché un
contenitore in cui ci puoi ficcare
veramente qualsiasi cosa e in
particolare nel ultimissimo periodo sto
seguendo un sacco lo stephen colbert
shock e mi son detto il mio canale non
ha una direzione in questo momento e mi
piace il fatto che non abbia una
direzione che guarda caso un contenitore
di roba sketch monologhi recensioni e mi
son detto perché non spendere due soldi
chiamare qualcuno per farmi aiutare e
mettere su una versione streaming sito
ovviamente youtube esca di un week
liscio uno show settimanale e fare e poi
da lì in poi per qualche mese
praticamente solo quello ma è un
dispendio di lavoro immane e io non lo
voglia di fare un cazzo perché a tutte
le persone a cui le ho detto questa cosa
mi hanno risposto fallo lo devi fare
perché una buona idea potrebbe venire
una cosa interessante pagare una merda
ma perché eroe una prova fanno fallo e
io ho preso benissimo sono partito a
mille ho iniziato anche a scrivere un po
di roba poi però mi sono arrivati i
soliti dubbi del tipo è ma è un casino
servirebbe uno studio servirebbe una
troupe per farla regia e cameraman
beh visto che di youtube e lo dobbiamo
fare striminzito sai cosa potrei fare
forma in casa in green screen
benvenuti nel primo week liscio di
youtube italia così ho provato proprio
improvvisando ero in pigiama mi sono
semplicemente messo una giacca del
vestito addosso con una scrivania una
tazza e un green screen a vedere se
potesse essere vagamente decente proprio
non ha abbastanza soldi da permettermi
allo studio vero quindi faremo tutto in
green screen
la risposta breve è no sembravo un cazzo
di cartomante nella provincia di torino
ma quella è stata una delle tante idee
che ho avuto
ma una delle poche che non è mai andata
via dalla mia testa quindi spero che
questo il regalo vi sia piaciuto
dovrebbe uscire ancora un video per il
milione che uscirà dopo natale ormai
grazie mille per essere passati i video
che voi avete visto sono privati e
rimangono privati e anche inutile che vi
scriviate al canale di marco de gasperi
tanto da lì non uscirà mai niente a
volevo dire un'ultima cosa volevo dire
ai miei colleghi youtuber quelli che
conosco di più e che sono praticamente
degli amici che questo canale marco de
gasperi io lo uso per insultarli sotto i
video senza farvi sapere che sono io
vedo un video che mi piace mi fico con
marco de gasperi e risolto completamente
random e questa sì che la magia del
natale